à l'autre bout du département une petite
fille a été renversée par une voiture
par la route il faudrait plus de deux
heures
l'hélicoptère lui sera sur zone en 25
minutes il faut rapatrier l'enfant au
service pédiatrique de Nancy
ou des chauffages de l'hôpital de Briey
c'est la panique
la maman tente de rassurer sa fille
il est là ne comprend pas le français
elle ne parle que le turc
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
[Musique]
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires
aux métiers extraordinaires
[Musique]
aujourd'hui immersion immédiate dans
l'un des plus grands centres
hospitaliers de France le CHU de Nancy
dans cet agglomération de plus de 400
000 habitants le service des urgences
tourne à plein régime c'est là que je
vais vivre pendant 96 heures
je vais apprendre à me protéger du virus
Ébola
je vais insister au sauvetage une petite
fille renversée par une voiture
ce petit bonhomme le cramponner dans
l'ambulance sur les petites routes de
Lorraine partagez le stress des
soignants devant la douleur des patients
et la détresse sous toutes ses formes
qu'est-ce que j'ai et quand j'aurai un
coup de blues je pourrais compter sur
Benjamin nous sommes toujours connectés
plongez dans un univers qui ne dort
jamais ou le contre-la-montre et la
règle
ou la vie ne tient souvent plus qu'à un
fil
parfait je ferme juste la porte de mon
bureau
là on risque pas de me demander un
diagnostic ou un truc comme ça parce que
vous verrez peut-être
j'ai laissé mes vêtements au vestiaire
une demande du service que je découvre
ici des fils plus de 45 000 patients par
an
aux manettes le docteur Lionel NAS sous
ses ordres 250 personnes
de quel âge qui a fait une chute mon
séjour démarre en douceur par la salle
de régulation la tour de contrôle des
urgences des pompiers sont en route on
envoie le message du Samu vous continuez
quand vous composez le 15 c'est dans une
salle comme celle-ci que vous arrivez
ici on reçoit 500 000 appels par an
chaque coup de téléphone est traité avec
la plus grande vigilance car chaque
seconde compte paradoxalement on ne fait
pas débuter les plus jeunes dans la
régulation il débute d'abord dans le
véhicule ou aux urgences et ensuite ils
intègrent la partie régulation que
lorsqu'ils ont une expérience suffisante
il faut aimer un petit peu effectivement
un petit peu ce stress de l'urgence mais
comme si cela est vrai pour les
réanimateurs les anesthésistes tous les
cardiologues des métiers ou en effectués
des gestes et où le temps compte un
petit peu un petit peu beaucoup
le calme qui règne dans cette salle
m'impressionne
ces médecins confirmés peuvent faire
face aux pires situations
[Musique]
97 ans les sous-dos c'est pas me dire si
elle respire ou pas elle est
inconsciente
oui bonjour madame je suis médecin du
Samu vous avez retrouvé votre maman
comme ça ou elle a fait un malaise
devant vous alors rien que du tout
le siège là pour l'étaler aux toilettes
bien et tout puis elle m'a demandé de la
recoucher j'ai eu difficultés à l'embête
dans le lit c'est une dame qui a des
problèmes de santé ou pas oui d'accord
tout de suite hein
vous avez déjà
donc j'ai pris ma décision donc j'ai
cliqué sur le moyen que je veux qu'on
engage et donc la stand de régulation
est en train d'envoyer le moyen que j'ai
choisi et vous avez choisi quoi une
ambiance de pompiers là pour aller au
plus rapide avoir un bilan rapidement je
vais la rappeler dans deux minutes pour
voir si la dame se réveille c'est un
malaise grave ou si vraiment ça n'arrêt
cardiaque parce que là elle vous dit
qu'elle est carrément décédée les gens
ne savent pas toujours des fois ça peut
être un malaise la levée donc ça peut
être aussi une chute de tension et quand
les gens perdent connaissance pas
toujours facile de faire la part des
choses
deux minutes plus tard le médecin
rappelle il va falloir tout tenter
jusqu'à l'arrivée des pompiers
vous allez vous mettre à genoux à côté
d'elle vous allez mettre vos mains au
milieu de sa poitrine et vous allez
faire des compressions thoraciques
d'accord donc il faut appuyer avec vos
deux mains sur le milieu de la poitrine
et vous allez compter et un et deux et
trois et vous n'avez pas vous arrêter
jusqu'à ce que les pompiers arrivent
ainsi que le médecin du Samu
d'accord
un petit peu plus vite madame continuez
je ne rêve pas je suis bien en train
d'assister un massage cardiaque à
distance
avec les deux mains vous mettez les deux
mains au milieu de la poitrine au milieu
je ne suis pas sûr dans une telle
situation que je réagirais avec le même
sang-froid
voilà à tout de suite
donc là on va initier la réanimation par
téléphone
de détresse respiratoire aiguë
[Musique]
il a
deuxième étape le cœur des urgences
c'est là que les médecins se relaient
toutes les 12 heures aujourd'hui c'est
le tour de garde d'Anne-Lise Véronèse
diplômée depuis deux ans elle a fait sa
spécialisation en médecine urgentiste
dans ce service
docteur véronès bonjour
un bureau central service d'accueil des
urgences un petit peu le centre
névralgique des
urgences donc ça c'est le tableau des
patients qui sont en salle d'examen en
box d'examen donc on va voir les
différents box le nom des passions alors
âge leur sexe là on a tout une catégorie
de cases qui vous représenterait qui les
a pris en charge à ce que le médecin l'a
déjà vu est-ce que c'est des étudiants à
ce que l'infirmier l'a installé tout ça
le recours pour lequel ils viennent on
va avoir
une dame qui vient pour une crise
d'épilepsie et puis après est-ce qu'il y
a des examens à faire des des
consultations biologiques des
radiologies
ceux qui sont à faire ceux qui sont
faits et puis ce qu'on pense que c'est
donc une crise d'épilepsie et ce qu'on
attend encore pour les patients voilà
une admission sur trois relève de la
médecine générale il n'y a pas danger de
vie ou de mort mais il faut agir vite
fracture blessures coupures ces
accidents de la vie quotidienne sont
pris très au sérieux ils sont traités
dans la filière courte
ça va rester comme ça
non mais si ça fait mal on peut percer
l'ombre par contre
[Musique]
je me suis
moi qui m'évanouis à la simple vue d'une
aiguille je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir fait
le bon choix
[Musique]
alors mission mission accomplie il y a
38 médecins aux urgences de Nancy la
moitié sont des femmes à 29 ans
Anne-Lise compte parmi les plus jeunes
je pense que quand on est comme moi une
femme d'autant plus jeune avec un
physique pas très imposant et que on a
des patients un peu un peu difficiles
qui peuvent être violent alcoolisé il
faut il faut pouvoir essayer de
s'imposer parce que
on se mangeait les urgences on s'entend
assez parlé c'est un lieu où il y a
comme beaucoup de violence on a des
patients
des patients alcoolisés qui peuvent être
violents il y a des patients les
patients très âgés qui sont qui sont des
membres qui peuvent aussi apporter notre
forme de violence même s'ils sont pas
physiquement ils sont pas responsables
de ce qu'ils font ils s'en rendent pas
compte
le problème c'est qu'au moindre malaise
les maisons de retraite s'en remettent
au SAMU
madame on va devoir vous faire un soin
ça va pas on va devoir faire un soin
madame ça va pas être très agréable il
faut beaucoup d'une sonde urinaire parce
que vous avez une infection quelque part
cette vieille dame qui souffre de fièvre
n'a plus toute sa tête est-ce que vous
savez où on est ici où est-ce qu'on est
ici vous savez
est-ce que vous savez où on est ici
comment vous vous appelez
samedi
[Musique]
c'est du savon madame ça fait pas mal
mais la vieille dame ne comprend pas ce
qu'on lui fait elle se braque une [ __ ]
[Musique]
où est-ce que vous avez
mangé
les personnes âgées c'est
un peu notre pain quotidien quoi c'est
des passions qu'on a le plus la
population vieillit c'est des gens qui
sont très fragiles et qui peuvent
décompenser très très vite sur une
pathologie en plus clair leur état peut
s'aggraver très rapidement
moi je sais bien vous embêter mais c'est
pour vous soigner
[Musique]
pas de service d'urgence sans ambulance
les semurs sont de véritables hôpitaux
roulants à leur bord un ambulancier un
médecin un infirmier et un interne
leur mission arrivait le plus vite
possible là où une fille est en danger
à chaque changement de garde est à
obligé la check-list
en intervention l'équipe peut être
confrontée à des patients en proie à des
douleurs insoutenables dans ce cas on a
un frigidaire et un coffre à stupéfiant
voilà on a quelques-uns qui sont
connus d'autres moins
morphine des drogues très puissantes
indispensables pour les traumatismes les
plus graves
gyrophare sirène carburant le véhicule
de l'ambulancier doit être prêt à bondir
les soignants eux vérifient leur
principal outils le défibrillateur
électrocardioscope vital pour connaître
l'activité du cœur et le relancer si
besoin voilà c'est un peu fastidieux
mais bon après ça fait c'est vraiment
c'est le premier truc qu'on fait en
arrivant après c'est vraiment une
rentrée quand on a le temps parce que
des fois on arrive ça sonne cette
rigueur elle est propre à chaque équipe
et tout le monde fait ça hyper
consciencieusement parce que si on
arrive sur une intervention et qui nous
manque quelque chose
d'important on va dire
ça peut nous poser des problèmes on sent
que vous vous parlez beaucoup tous les
uns les autres
c'est important il y a de la cohésion
entre kifiée c'est très très important
on a tous besoin des autres mais on est
complémentaires
alors là vous êtes en pleine réparation
imaginons que ça sonne là que vous soyez
appelé qu'est-ce que vous finissez pas
vous partez tout de suite
l'infirmière termine de ranger et puis
on part directement
d'ailleurs nous partons tout de suite
une femme vient de faire un malaise
[Musique]
où est-ce qu'on va alors
priori qui ferait des mathémère
les symptômes alors chaque seconde
compte
[Musique]
c'est au beau milieu d'un cimetière que
l'accident est arrivé
chaque cas avec une forme de stress ou
un petit peu de stress on sait jamais
sur quoi on va tomber mais
après
il y a beaucoup là on n'a pas réussi à
avoir d'éléments parce que les gens
étaient paniqués alors soit c'est
la panique justifie auquel cas
soit comme c'est souvent le cas c'est la
panique qui est pas forcément justifie
en tout cas il y a pas forcément
d'urgence vitale mais bon dans le doute
il vaut mieux être engagé
les pompiers arrivent souvent les
premiers ils sont déjà en action et
viennent de placer la femme dans leur
véhicule à l'abri du froid
alors
la poitrine du tout hein d'accord et
quand vous avez vomi là vous avez vomi
brutalement
vous avez déjà dit
j'avais l'impression d'avoir
pour faire de l'anémie non pas
spécialement
parce que j'étais un petit peu pâle a
priori votre hémoglobine un petit peu
basse aussi
alors comment plus vous avez perdu du
sang c'est pour ça que je vous pose la
question
reste à savoir pourquoi vous en avez
perdu de ce que vous me dites il y a des
histoires de douleurs d'estomac juste
comme ça ça peut correspondre à un
ulcère qui saignerait au fur et à mesure
et qui vous met en anony donc il va
falloir qu'on vérifie tout ça
pendant que l'équipe du Samu cherche les
causes du malaise les pompiers prennent
en charge la famille de la victime
mais déjà c'est déjà de faire des
examens complémentaires là les
relativement stable il y a pas de
pronostic vital engagé pendant le moment
donc s'il faut quand même surveillance à
se rapprocher mais
on va on va faire tout ça à l'hôpital ou
de chômage le déchoquage c'est
l'anti-chambre de la réanimation un lieu
où l'état du patient est surveillé à la
loupe ça va
[Musique]
l'équipe médicale ne connaît toujours
pas l'origine du malaise
ou des choquage des examens approfondis
seront réalisés une chose est sûre cette
dame ne rentrera pas tout de suite chez
elle
[Musique]
en début de soirée c'est l'heure de
pointe entre la valse des ambulances et
le ballet des brancards une personne
joue un rôle crucial l'infirmier
d'orientation et d'accueil dont le
jargon on l'appelle le trieur ce soir
c'est Cédric Scherrer il rencontre
chaque patient et les classes par ordre
de gravité
alors ça va aller non attends voilà
c'est ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous évaluez
votre douleur à combien vous savez que
je cherche à peu près combien vous avez
mal bonjour
il y a pas de problème je vous cherchez
ça d'accord je reviens
bonsoir alors
les urgences enregistrent en moyenne 120
ans par jour et plus de 160 en hiver les
cas les plus graves ou la vie est en jeu
sont traités dans les trois minutes mais
les patients valides qui viennent pour
un acte de médecine générale peuvent
attendre plusieurs heures surtout en
soirée quand les autres praticiens ont
fermé boutique
ça c'est mon boulot
moi je en fait je j'évalue rapidement la
situation et je vois s'il faut les
installer tout de suite ou si on peut un
petit peu de temporiser il y a quand
même pas mal de gens ou c'est une
urgence ressentie c'est pas une vraie
urgence pour nous point de vue médical
monsieur ouais je vous mets un petit
coussin avec un petit drap allez-y tous
les jours savoir Monsieur Kern au niveau
de la douleur maintenant actuellement
tout de suite on en est où allez-y
serrez moins fort les mains fort fort
les mains d'accord ok ok c'est bon
madame parfait pas de douleur à Madame
on est bien d'accord vous avez pas mal à
la tête d'accord ce que je redoute c'est
de passer à côté de quelque chose c'est
à dire pas à détecter qu'un patient va
se dégrader rapidement et me dire bah il
peut attendre et puis que la personne se
dégrade que je le loupe parce que il y a
certains diagnostics ça peut être du
digestif ça peut être du cardiaque alors
de me dire il est un peu mal au ventre
et qu'en fait ça se voit après une
cardiaque et qu'il fasse un arrêt
cardiaque et qui décède ici sans qu'on
les sans qu'on les vues
aux urgences il y a aussi la clientèle
du samedi soir
[Musique]
on va souffler un petit coup dans la
machine
[Musique]
en fait d'accord allez
la police a retrouvé cet homme minerte
sur un trottoir
il faudrait souffler un peu plus
longtemps
[Musique]
ça va aller jusqu'ici
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup vous avez
beaucoup consommé ce soir beaucoup oui
beaucoup beaucoup d'alcool fort
[Musique]
on calme la crise et on les revoit le
lendemain une fois qu'ils ont des grisé
on perd 0,15 d'alcoolémie par heure la
particularité de ses patients là c'est
il faut qu'on évite qu'il vomisse dans
leur branche ça veut dire inhaler pour
nous donc on va peut-être le mettre un
petit peu en PLS sur le côté comme ça si
vomit il ne vomira pas dans ses poumons
ce qui peut le tuer quoi
à 1h30 du matin tous s'emballe une dame
seule et paniquée a appelé le 15 c'est
le grand patron qui est de garde ce soir
de quoi s'agit-il
je me cramponne ça secoue fort
l'ambulancier connaît par cœur le
moindre nid de poule de son département
les limitations de vitesse en revanche
ne sont pas sans souci je vais faire
comme si je n'avais pas peur
[Musique]
là qu'est-ce qui a justifié
l'intervention
alors douleur thoracique ça reste motif
assez habituel parce que si c'est un
infarctus c'est une filière très
particulière qui va directement dans le
service de cardiologie et donc on peut
pas se permettre de le faire arriver aux
urgences sinon on perd trop de temps
derrière
[Musique]
nous sommes sur les lieux en moins de 20
minutes
la vieille dame est étendue sur son
canapé c'est elle-même qui a donné
l'alerte
bonjour ça va madame on va s'occuper de
vous d'accord
rassurez-vous madame d'accord
montrez-moi où vous avez mal exactement
au milieu c'est comme si on enfonce une
aiguille là ou si ça sert en entier
pas du tout d'accord c'est la première
fois que vous avez une douleur comme ça
que vous avez mal et depuis huit jours
c'est tout le temps vous avez mal ou ça
va ça vient
après avoir vérifié qu'elle était bien
consciente après avoir pris la tension
artérielle l'équipe cherche du côté du
cœur
bougez pas respirez tranquillement on va
faire un électrocardiogramme
mais sur l'électrocardiogramme aucun
signe d'infarctus
madame
il est bien d'accord il y a pas il y a
pas de problème au cœur d'accord
[Rires]
de trouver sa place dans un moment
pareil respirez doucement madame ce
qu'on va faire on va vous mettre sur le
brancard et on vous amené dans
l'ambulance on vous amener après à Nancy
à l'hôpital ok d'accord
donner les clés on entre brutalement
dans l'intimité des patients alors
autant repartir sur la pointe des pieds
voilà c'est bon il est temps pourri
[Musique]
dans l'ambulance la situation s'aggrave
et l'état de la route n'arrange rien
durant le trajet de retour la chaîne des
secours se met en place le service
d'accueil des urgences a prévu une
entrée prioritaire
elle est toujours la plus forte un peu
moins fort
l'admission ne se fait pas au pas de
charge mais presque car la situation est
préoccupante
c'est conforme à ce que vous pensiez ou
c'est un peu plus embêtant de ce que je
pensais
contrôler les focards de grains voir si
une modification par rapport au premier
tracé
puis attendre les résultats du bilan
sanguin
compléter l'image libre
ou des shockage l'équipe s'affaire de
nouveaux tests sont pratiqués
l'état de la patiente empire
[Musique]
on assise à une intervention qui est
quand même
assez pénible parce que pour l'instant
ils savent pas ce qu'elle a
envie
qui était normal madame Le Mans
ça va
regardez-moi un petit peu madame Le Mans
fidèle à ce qu'on à ce qu'on pressant et
perçoit d'eux depuis que nous sommes
arrivés donc les gens très calme très
doux très à l'écoute très
rassurant
il est presque 3 heures du matin et ils
sont d'attaque
moi beaucoup moins grave
au bout de 10 minutes un nouvel
électrocardiogramme par l'enfant
ça y est ouais voilà c'est dingue ça
fait plus oui mode métabolique quoi là
c'est ça
y est vous avez un diagnostics
complètement modifié son tracé donc un
tableau de nécrose myocarde donc vous
êtes la garde
une coronaire une artère qui arrive au
cœur est en train de se boucher
j'assiste un infarctus du myocarde en
temps réel
je vous diriez qu'il a eu très très
chaud avec initialement oui parce que la
même chose à la maison non surveillé ça
peut poser des soucis
donc
voilà une électro de galère évolutive
tout n'est pas encore réglé il va
falloir aller faire un geste
sur la coronaire pour essayer de
déboucher la corneille
le travail des urgentistes s'arrête ici
la patiente sera opérée dans l'heure par
le cardiologue de garde et ressortira de
l'hôpital dix jours plus tard
[Musique]
la nuit n'est pas terminée en attendant
le prochain appel d'urgence je partage
une pause avec l'équipe de garde et je
retrouve Géraldine celle qui a déclenché
le massage cardiaque par téléphone ce
matin qu'est-ce que vous craignez de
plus quand vous sortez en intervention
comme ça
après le stress pour l'équipe médicale
c'est de se retrouver en difficulté par
rapport à ses connaissances
se dire est-ce que je sais prendre en
charge telle ou telle pathologie je
pense que c'est une philosophie de vie
moi cette profession parce qu'on est
autiste tout le temps avec son pote
après
ça dossier relativiser beaucoup je
trouve quand même les choses comme elles
ont tous les jours et j'imagine qu'il y
a des cas qui vous restent en tête
avis non je pense que c'est bien que ça
reste pour certaines choses parce que
encore une fois quelqu'un qui est
complètement détaché des choses ça sera
pas un bon médecin ou un bon soignant
ce moment-là on mettrait un robot et
puis on s'affranchirait de ses problèmes
là après l'inverse celui qui ne dort
plus toutes les nuits parce qu'il
cauchemars sur telle situation il faut
qu'il arrête
[Musique]
j'ai dormi trois heures mais comme tout
le monde est sur le pont je reprends du
service
aux urgences les 35 heures on ne connaît
pas autour de moi toutes ces femmes
travaillent au moins 60 heures par
semaine
[Musique]
je vais dimanche
24 heures
et donc la petite pause en cours de
journée elle est indispensable
le café est indispensable et puis là ça
va ce que il y a pas encore trop
d'attente donc il y a pas de ce sens en
fait le problème c'est que la machine à
café est au milieu de la salle de la
tente des familles et que quand il y a
beaucoup de monde et ben même si ça fait
10 heures qu'on a beau qu'on bosse qu'on
s'est pas posé qu'on a pas mangé que
voilà il y a toujours cette culpabilité
de passer devant les familles qui ont
l'impression qu'on ne fait rien et qu'on
boit des cafés pendant que ils attendent
et que à ce moment-là
je suis de garde aux urgences est-ce que
je peux vous rappeler dans 10 minutes
madame
voilà je vous remercie au revoir à toi
aussi ta banque ton machin ton truc qui
t'appelle toujours au mauvais moment la
banque l'assurance tu vois pas décrocher
donc là c'est la vie privée qui en prend
un coup ça vous avez pas le temps
c'est sûr
mais donc ma fille elle est trimballée
entre les grands-mères avec mon mari qui
gère heureusement qu'il gère bien et oui
de la vie privée on prend la rejoint que
c'est sûr et votre mari dit rien il est
très compréhensif mon mari mais oui mais
c'est pas évident pour lui non plus
c'est sûr il est dans le milieu et
heureusement peut-être pour ça qu'il est
compréhensible
parce que sinon il le serait moins mais
sinon il serait là avec moi
mais ce que cette énergie que ça vous
demande dans le travail vous pouvez
aussi le mettre dans le dans la vie
privée et là ah oui complètement
la famille est encore avec ou pas
j'arrive
je suis là j'arrive
je laisse le docteur Véronèse retourner
au feu moi j'ai rendez-vous avec
Benjamin enfin presque j'enchaîne les
nuits blanches pendant que lui cela
coule douce à Tahiti
salut Benjamin ça va
ça va bien ça va super
tu as vu ça petite je voulais être
médecin donc je trouvais ça absolument
génial bon j'ai un peu peur du sang un
peu peur de même les petits bobos que
j'ai pu déjà commencer à voir et me
donne un peu la mal au cœur mais je
prends sur moi Benjamin tu acceptes que
de jolis infirmières te prennent en
photo
allez venez voir les filles je vais
faire un selfie avec vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
aux urgences on est on n'est pas à des
situations compliquées et qui était plus
difficilement le plus difficile c'est
quand tu te retrouves avec le médecin à
arriver sur un appel d'urgence justement
où tu débarques dans des familles les
gens comprennent pas forcément ce que tu
fais là c'est ni tout à fait le moment
de les déranger ni rien tu vois des gens
qui sont en situation de détresse
absolue donc oui ça c'est difficile ne
serait-ce que par pudeur tu as pas envie
de perturber le travail des équipes donc
voilà tu te fais petite souris
dans ta blouse blanche mais voilà
on roule vite ça roule vite ça roule
très très vite et je peux dire que quand
tu es à Nancy et que il fait pas beau et
que tu es en pleine nuit noire et qui a
un brouillard et que tu vois pas à 20
mètres oui c'est très impressionnant
donc ouais j'en menais pas l'argent très
très honnêtement bon allez c'est bon on
vous dérange plus
salut
à bientôt
je suis malheureusement pas très
optimiste qu'on puisse le sauver
dans les plus grands CHU de France
l'alerte bola a été lancé évidemment
c'est tombé pendant ma semaine
d'immersion je vais donc apprendre à me
protéger du virus comme tout le
personnel médical aide-soignant
infirmier médecin ils doivent savoir
accueillir et soigner un malade sans se
contaminer se protéger de liquide
biologique c'est se protéger de quel
liquide donc de tout liquide biologique
qu'on peut excréter donc le sang les
selles la sueur le sperme les urines
donc on retient en S comme ça
c'est un bon moyen mnémotechnique donc
c'est la règle des 5S en fait
tous les vêtements sont à usage unique
chaussures sur chaussures double paire
de gants sans couleur peau
mais aussi combinaison à glissières
spéciales et les masques
on va bien passer la barrette sur le
haut
pour vérifier si le masque est bien
étanche on va appuyer et on va inspirer
fortement si le masque se colorisage
c'est qu'il est bien ici on a inscrit
voilà très bien mais je vais pas pouvoir
tenir comme ça à moins de faire un
malaise vagal je vous annonce on met la
capuche maintenant
et on mange du stand le protocole est
ultra contraignant et bola provoque une
fièvre hémorragique le virus est mortel
dans près d'un cas sûr de vous voyez là
il y a du lapin voilà tout à fait donc
le binôme va s'occuper de bien réajuster
façon aussi à ce que la personne voit
Hitler voilà là c'est tout à fait bien
il y a plus de peau visible
sur 10000 personnes contaminées plus de
la moitié n'a pas survécu et il n'existe
toujours pas de traitement homologué
nous sommes opérationnels je n'entends
rien je ne sens rien je me demande
comment dans un tel scaphandre on peut
encore soigner des gens vous pouvez
parler un petit peu plus fort parce
qu'on entend juste rien quoi je vous
emmène où est notre patient d'accord
si en France le risque d'épidémie est
faible la probabilité de prendre en
charge un patient contaminé est-elle
très élevée
[Musique]
le potage d'urgence c'est un transit
donc le patient c'est pourquoi il a le
masque
pour être rapatrié aux maladies
infectieuses ou secteur P3
elle a l'air mal en point la petite dame
le risque ça fait partie de vos métiers
c'est le risque est beau là il est plus
effrayant que les autres
contamination donc nous on a quand même
relativement peur enfin moi
personnellement voilà c'est quand même
quelque chose qui fait peur à tout le
monde et le fait d'avoir une formation
et de s'entraîner ça nous rassure quand
même
et on commence à avoir le la 2 et là
perception
et les changer au niveau du bruit au
niveau de même de toucher
on pourrait pas faire grand chose
un petit peu chaud
comme ça
vous êtes habillé vous déjà vous avez
fait le ah oui oui nous depuis longtemps
sur d'autres types de procédures dans le
stress ou les problèmes énervé c'est
chimiques du côté SAMU on est formé à la
vie à jouer
cela fait une heure que je mijote dans
ma combinaison d'astronaute je n'ai
qu'une envie mon débarrasser mais le
déshabillage est extrêmement dangereux
un simple contact avec l'extérieur de ma
tenue et je risque la contamination il
faut toujours s'équiper et se
déshabiller à deux parce que là moi j'ai
déjà touché donc j'ai fait une
d'abord commencer en jusqu'en bar
maximum
si la charlotte
[Musique]
les avant-bras
pendant que j'apprends à me battre
contre bola
les équipes elles ne sont pas
Hélène vigneron et la doyenne des
infirmières de l'hôpital elle forme avec
le docteur et le pilote l'équipe
d'intervention héliportée du Samu de
Lorraine
à l'autre bout du département une petite
fille a été renversée par une voiture
par la route il faudrait plus de deux
heures l'hélicoptère lui sera sur zone
en 25 minutes
la petite a été prise en charge par
l'hôpital de Briey dans le nord du
département mais le scanner vient de
tomber en panne impossible de connaître
l'étendue des dégâts il faut rapatrier
l'enfant au service pédiatrique de Nancy
ou des choquage de l'hôpital de Briey
c'est la panique
la maman tente de rassurer sa fille
il est là ne comprend pas le français
elle ne parle que le turc
[Musique]
d'accord
l'infirmière prépare la mer à la
séparation vous voyez que quelques fois
moins tendance à vouloir pleurer
[Musique]
vigneron est infirmière urgentiste
depuis plus de 30 ans elle sait parler
aux enfants malgré la barrière de la
langue
[Applaudissements]
tu comprends pas ce que je te
dis mais c'est pas grave
on va se promener d'accord et je reste
avec toi d'accord
[Musique]
mademoiselle
c'est bon on peut y aller
tu me l'as pris
en moins de 10 minutes la petite est
embarquée dans l'hélicoptère malgré le
vacarme l'enfant ne crie plus pour la
calmer l'infirmière lui montre un petit
dessin animé sur son téléphone
arrivé à Nancy direction les urgences
pédiatriques pour une batterie de tests
[Musique]
pour s'assurer qu'il n'y a rien de grave
la petite restera 48 heures sous haute
surveillance
c'est rigolo quand même
il est à ressortira de l'hôpital sonné
mais indemne
[Musique]
au bureau central une nouvelle course
commence la chasse au lit de nombreux
patients doivent être hospitalisés mais
il n'y a pas de place dans les étages
c'est embouteillage paralyse le circuit
des soins en 5 ans l'affluence
journalière aux urgences a presque
doublée
les médecins de garde placent au cas par
cas les malades les plus urgents
pendant ce temps le sas d'accueil se
remplit inexorablement
la population agit augmente et c'est
particulièrement criant en hiver
[Musique]
ces différents
disponibles pour le service des urgences
sur toute la nuit et on refait un tour
des lits à 4h du matin avec s'il y a eu
des évolutions ou des eNVOLIS parfois il
y a des décès dans les services donc on
apprend les décès et on pousse à nous
libère des lits
pour vous dans votre service
[Musique]
là moi j'ai deux patients qui ont plus
75 ans qui sont là depuis 7h de temps
sur un rencard et ils auraient dû être
toutes les idées plus tôt mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de solution
hospitalisation après l'idéal ça aurait
été de la gériatrie mais c'est pour ça
que c'était la première question est-ce
qu'il y a des gériatrie parce que
de médecine
donc bon on va essayer de faire avec
mais bon on a 40 passions aux urgences
il y en a un certain nombre d'acheter là
donc il est probable que demain matin il
nous en reste qui est des gens qui
dorment aux urgent cette nuit quoi sur
la banque
pénurie de lit est un casse-tête et un
gros facteur de stress pour les équipes
ça ressemble un peu au principe des
chaises musicales quoi c'est tout c'est
une chaise musicale orientée parce que
j'ai un peu l'impression dans le jeu
enfin de ce que je reconnais que c'est
un peu au hasard on tombe sur une chaise
libre on a de la chance là on essaye
quand même de caser ceux qui sont
prioritaires pour affiliation
parfois les patients font irruption
menottent au poignet s'il vous plaît
lors d'un contrôle de police cette jeune
femme venue d'Europe de l'Est a tenté de
s'enfuir et s'est blesser à la jambe
avant tout audition il faut la soigner
ça va bien se passer
désinfectant antidouleur
10 minutes et 5 points de suture plus
tard elle prend le chemin du
commissariat sous bonne escorte
[Musique]
aux urgences les gardes dure 24 heures
12 au bureau d'accueil et 12 en
intervention sur le terrain pour le
docteur Véronèse la nuit ne fait que
commencer
c'est parti
on y va
[Musique]
de toute façon pour le dîner c'est raté
il est 21h30 et c'est le deuxième appel
cette nuit les urgences cardiaques
s'enchaînent
bon ben j'aurais jamais fini de manger
ce kebab c'est la malédiction du kebab
la famille d'un agriculteur a donné la
l'air quand la nuit est tombée le vieil
homme n'était toujours pas rentré de son
champ
qui a été retrouvé à côté de son
tracteur inanimé
quand nous arrivons les pompiers
essayent de faire redémarrer le cœur
depuis plus d'un quart d'heure
ils peuvent encore espérer relancer la
machine pendant une petite demi-heure à
condition d'intervenir le plus vite
possible après le malaise seul problème
on ne sait pas combien de temps l'homme
est resté inconscient avant l'arrivée
des pompiers il faut préparer l'épouse
de la victime au pire bonjour je suis le
médecin du Samu vous êtes
sa femme faut que je parle un petit peu
de votre mari il a des problèmes de
santé et prendre du quai d'occa du
diabète
le souci c'est donc il a été retrouvé en
arrêt cardio respiratoire ça veut dire
que son cœur s'est arrêté
je ne sais absolument pas vous dire à
l'heure actuelle pourquoi
là on est en train de
tenter de le réanimer mais
vu les délais
au moment où ça s'est passé le moment où
les pompiers ont commencé à réanimer je
suis malheureusement pas très optimiste
qu'on puisse le sauver
[Musique]
les médecins urgentistes vont faire une
dernière tentative
on remet un coup un coup d'Adré et puis
si ça fait rien on en rattrape
l'adrénaline c'est le remède de la
dernière chance
on n'a pas réussi à faire repartir son
cœur je suis désolé de devoir vous
annoncer ça mais votre mari est décédé
ensemble
ma question c'est savoir si autopsie ou
pas il y a pas de traces sur le corps il
a pas de problème de santé donc faut
voir conjointement avec
la publicité de police judiciaire la
gendarmerie si pour eux c'est une
situation qui leur paraît suspecte ou si
comme là on part sur quelque chose qui a
l'air quand même plutôt de d'une morte
naturelle
probablement un infarctus ou quelque
chose comme ça après un nouvel examen du
corps le docteur conclura un infarctus
la mort est bien accidentelle
[Musique]
pour tenir les équipes doivent être
soudées à l'hôpital mais aussi au dehors
ce soir des internes faites leur fin de
stage ce qui ne sont pas de garde ont
tombé la blouse
oui
tout au long de nos journées ils sont
parfois très difficiles
là on est vraiment nous je pense on est
vraiment nous on n'est pas soumis au
stress aux effectifs on n'est pas soumis
au strate des patients on n'est pas
soumis au stress du manque de lit là on
lâche la pression c'est complètement
lourd notre quotidien c'est quand même
des choses qui sont tristes
comme la maladie la souffrance
on a la misère sociale la mise en
médicale on a plein de choses et du coup
c'est sûr que tu viens on a besoin des
compenser
par rapport à ça
décompresser ensemble pour ne pas
décompenser quand on se retrouve seul ce
soir ils ont appliqué leur devise à la
lettre
[Musique]
de ces 96 heures passées aux urgences je
garderai en mémoire ces accros de
l'adrénaline ces soignants qui
n'attendent ni reconnaissances ni
remerciment pour se démener au service
des autres
depuis mon départ l'équipe a enchaîné
les accidents cardiovasculaires les
drames de la route les accouchements à
domicile et beaucoup beaucoup de nuits
blanches le dispositif Ébola a été
déclenché vrai frayeur mais fausse
alerte heureusement ce n'était qu'une
simple crise de paludisme
bon je vais reprendre des forces avant
ma prochaine immersion alors à toi de
jouer Benjamin
[Musique]